[Musique]
une peluche qui vous tend les bras en
tête de gondole désormais en entrant
dans ce magasin vous êtes d'emblée dans
l'ambiance le de pièges commerciale de
noël dans lequel nous aimons parfois
tombés sur refaire et pas question pour
le directeur de rater le coche
le mois de décembre représente presque
le double d'un mois normal en terme de
chiffre d'affaires sur le mois décembre
c'est le premier chiffre d'affaires de
tous les mois de l'année
donc il est bien entendu que si vous
loupez votre mois de décembre vous ne
serez pas dans vos objectifs
tous les rayons sont concernés mais
celui des jouets reste emblématique ne
serait ce que pour installer les clients
dans l'esprit de la ve
il faut pas moins de 10 personnes durant
cinq jours pour refaire entièrement la
des centrales au coût d'impression
hambourg de stress parce qu'il faut bien
il faut bien il faut gérer le matin est
arrivé tôt le seront pas rentables pour
manger il faut il faut suivre donc les
demandes des clients mais il faut tout
faire pour vous êtes le député lors ce
matin je suis arrivé à 7h30 parce qu'il
se rangeait ses 26 à 21 euros donc
citant la montée en puissance est
progressive
mais malgré tout au fil des ans les
jouets subissent la concurrence féroce
des articles numérique et se vante de
moins en moins qu'en baisse de 20% en
cinq ans et tablettes sont là ont
tendance à isoler la famine donc nous
famille on nage ou plus on ne s'amuse
plus on ne rit plus tout le monde est
dans son coin donc ça veut dire les
enfants 50 avec les parents les
portables les ordinateurs et en fait on
ne fait plus rien sans doute pourquoi
c'est dommage
dans les jours à venir et à moins
d'habiter une autre planète il sera
impossible de passer outre la frénésie
de noël
l'essentiel étant finalement peut-être
de passer du temps en famille